maybe you've seen Atlas the humanoid
robot that can run do backflips and
parkour or spot mini the Internet's
favorite robotic dog which opens doors
for its friends yes every time Boston
Dynamics drops a video
the Internet has itself a freak out its
latest release spot many doing the
running man to Uptown longer and the
reaction online is well-deserved these
are some of the most impressive robots
on earth but can they make the
transition from Internet stardom to
real-world people seem to love looking
at it I don't know exactly what the
fascination is they don't seem afraid of
it they mostly are drawn to it but the
truth is these demonstrations don't show
typical behavior but rather the very
best performance that robots can muster
it took over 20 tries to get Atlas to do
this trick once I got the hang of things
though it could pull it off 90% of the
time and we honestly don't know the full
extent of spot minis abilities because
Lawson dynamics is a very secretive
company at the very least we know that
in some of spot minis demos
the robot is remote-controlled but we
also know spot mini can map environments
and then navigate them autonomously
which is a major step forward for robots
like this the core of spot many is its
mobility it can go in a large variety of
terrains it kind of takes care of all
the things it has to worry about to keep
itself balanced so that if there's a
person involved they can just give it
high-level guidance if there's AI
involved it can give a higher level x
and the robot takes care of everything
else so it's a mixture of the mechanical
design which has some clever things done
and the software but it don't do that
spot minis design has its roots in a
rougher looking robot called big doll
and we learned a ton about the role of
dynamic control and balance
building that but it was totally a
prototype it had a noisy engine that
required lots of continuous maintenance
we were flying by the seat of our pants
but with once that started to mature we
did a couple of other projects we did a
big walking robot that could carry 400
pounds and then we did a fast one called
the cheetah and we started to see that
if you did the right kind of design you
could really have a much more functional
almost product level quite a pet all of
that led to the original larger version
of spot so spot had great performance
the best of any robot we'd ever built
and sort of paved the way for them doing
a smaller version which is the spot and
oh how far spot mini has come sensors
allow it to automatically keep its
balance even if a human assaultive and
if you pilot it to where an obstacle
it'll redirect on its own and it has an
attachable arm that can move much like a
human's and no that's not its head
that's its hand we can rotate move up
and down and bend at the elbow it comes
equipped with a camera which might make
it good for things like inspecting
construction sites when it hits the
market next year which leads us back to
the million dollar question what is spot
many actually good for for starters you
won't be seen them in people's homes any
time soon
you know we're focusing on
business-to-business right now not on
consumers the world just hasn't seen a
machine like this so Boston Dynamics is
aligned to a large degree on customers
to tell it what works well we've
designed spot to be a customizable
platform so it's a platform like an
Android or even an iOS phone is a
platform the basic idea is that we're
going to provide a set of functionality
and then other people including our own
applications groups will provide both
hardware and software that works on that
platform to customize it for specific
applications you know we don't know what
the big successes will be yet but we're
looking at construction
commercial security some municipal
security entertainment which might get
you thinking that a robot likes pot mini
will steal your job but at least in the
near term the machines are more likely
to supplement human labour not replace
it and yes spot many will continue to
wow us all online but it's the market
that will determine its future so if
you've been looking for a dance
instructor that never gets tired now's
the time to speak up